i know that like you know role has been
married for a good chunk of his life so
he hasn't seen this but
like every single relationship from my
20s onwards
has always been an upgrade um there was
a stand-up comic that made a joke about
this once where
you know like women will never go down
financially with men men
men generally speaking especially once
they get red pilled will tolerate less
and less crap and often
you know women or a female primary
social order will point and sputter at
these guys and say oh you're immature
you're a commitment phobe you know fill
in the
narrative or the point and sputter
reason why you're not
you know settling down for this you know
single mom with three kids in tow from
two different fathers and an extra 50
pounds before you knew her
in her 20s when she dumped you because
you've gotten better and you tolerate
less bs and it's not misogyny it's not
women hate it's just
you know there's a lot of people out
there that can that get that confusion
it's just no as you get better
and you and your smv goes up and you
make more money you learn some game you
know you put a dent in the universe
your value is greater than what hers is
because her
her peaks in her 20s you know it's 22 23
24 after that she's generally speaking
on the decline you know sometimes you
can push it off a little bit with some
good health habits
but she's on the decline i mean it's
it's just the reality of life
right when you were reading um the
iron rule number seven uh which is you
know never never root through garbage
the other part of that i think is
almost more important and they and that
is that it is
time better spent developing new women
and new
prospective women than it is trying to
restart
or to like repair an old relationship
because when you get into that when
you're like when you get in this mode of
thinking like
couples like when they go to like
marriage counseling or something
they're already in this mode and the
mode is you're negotiating genuine
desire
when you first met that girl that you
were with and then you broke up with her
for whatever like
she broke up with you or whatever for
whatever reason prior to that breakup
when you guys were getting together
hopefully it was based on genuine desire
she actually wanted to get with you and
you guys were having hot monkey sex for
the first three months in the honeymoon
period kind of thing
and then you were foolish enough to move
in with her or whatever
you know and you ended up having this
sort of long-term relationship
and so at some point something shifted
from genuine desire
to sort of negotiating desire and when
you break
up with that person and then you and you
come back to it even if it
works out for you you're negotiating the
terms for you coming back together
so yeah you might have that hot you know
br makeup sex
for a little while and you might go
through another sort of honeymoon period
but after a while you're always going to
have that one time
where you guys broke up or that one time
we had a break and she went and banged
the guy in the foam cannon party in
cancun
and that's always going to be part of
your relationship with that person
so what i always said is like the second
part of that is this is that it's always
time better spent to get with somebody
who doesn't know you who you have a
fresh start with
who you can learn from your mistakes if
you have made any or whatever
like maybe it's just you being more
cautious or wary so you have more
experience and you move on from there
this is also why i say that spinning
plates should be
part of your your game your plan uh from
the time you're like 18 all the way
until you're about 30 31 32 maybe even
beyond that
because what that does is it does two
things it prevents you
from getting slipping into the idea that
oh this is one special girl for me
and and she's the only one for me like
you you start you know
fixating you catch feelings or get one
itis uh
when you are um when you're spinning
plates when you're dating
non-exclusively and i mean that in terms
of not in poly you're not like have one
one main girl and you've got like a few
side girls i mean every one of your
girls with side girls
when you do that you're doing your
you're you're
for stalling i guess the or preventing
one itis preventing the soulmate myth
you are in a condition of abundance at
least
mentally even if you've only got like
two girls or three girls at least you're
in a position of abundance where you can
say i can generate more options
that options is what is where confidence
comes from so you're also developing
confidence
the sec and then fourthly um you are
also developing experience so you
understand women's nature better because
you're dealing with different women
and you're seeing what it is that you
need and what you know from a long-term
partner assuming that's what you want to
do in the future
so you've got abundance you've got
experience you've got uh inch
somewhat insurance against this you know
the soulmate thing
you're getting you got experience
everything else and
that's one of the reasons why i keep
saying you know spinning plates is a
good thing for guys particularly when
you're young
it's not just about getting you know
hitting every girl you can
you know for the sake of the sex it's
because there's other things that go
along with it
you